[Musique]
elle s'appelait dina et comme toutes les
filles de 14 ans dina avait des rêves
pourtant dans la nuit du 4 au 5 octobre
la jeune fille a mis fin à ses jours
seul dans sa chambre ne supportant plus
le harcèlement permanent de ses
camarades d'école moqué pour son
orientation sexuelle et pour avoir
confié à celle qu'elle pensait être ses
amis est lgbt dina a vécu pendant
plusieurs années l'enfer dimanche une
marche blanche réunissant 1400 personnes
a été organisée à mulhouse pour lui
rendre hommage et pour dire plus jamais
ça
ce soir sa maman samira et son frère
ryan sont sur notre plateau pour alerter
et pour que dina ne soient jamais
oubliées
merci ryan d'être là merci ça m'ira
je sais que c'est très dur pour vous de
revoir ces images c'est
c'est un déchirement le 5 octobre
dernier
votre fille est ta soeur ryan s'est
suicidé elle avait 14 ans
comment vous l'avez découvert
je me suis levé à 2 heures du matin pour
aller aux toilettes
et j'ai vu de la lumière dans sa chambre
je voulais rentrer pour la grande et lui
dire il est 2 heures
et en fait
quand on rend dans la chambre à droite
il ya son lit à gauche et à la revoir
donc à droite elle n'était pas dans son
lit et j'ai juste tourner la tête et je
les trouvais
accroché à son dakar
avec une ceinture
et j'ai pas compris ce qui se passait en
fait jugé t j'avais même lui dire mais
qu'est ce que tu fais ce que tu fais
accrocher à ce placard
et quand j'ai compris
j'ai essayé de
de la soulager en fait je les ai privé
les jambes j'ai appelé mon mari qui venu
en courant qu'il a décoché qui a
commencé les massages cardiaques
mais elle était déjà morte
elle était déjà partie ça fait je les
vues des premières des premiers regards
j'ai vu qu'elle n'était plus là
et puis voilà et après ça s'est enchaîné
jusqu'à demain
vous saviez qu'il y avait ce harcèlement
constant à l'école où elle n'était pas
du tout au courant elle vous en aviez
jamais non non on savait qu'il y avait
du harcèlement mais avait commencé dans
la fin quatrième c'est ça voilà avec
d'abord ses copines et puis après ça
fait un effet boule de neige
et commence à se matérialiser commencer
s'est
éloignée elle avait ouvert un groupe ma
fille faisait partie ce groupe aussi
donc
l insulte elle à traiter de tous les
noms je les sorties du groupe je les
bloquer
je lai bloqué du groupe je vais sortie
de tous les réseaux parce qu'elle l'a
quand je la sors tes doigts de sa part
revenez sur messenger quand je la sortie
de l'intégrale revenait sur instagram
ensuite je lui ai mis des
parce qu'elle l'appelait le matin à 7
heures comme ça le comme ça ma fille
elle elle va au collège avec une boule
au ventre look à 7 heures du matin je
lui bloquer les appels entrants et
sortants je laissais juste les numéros
important c'est à dire le mien et celui
de son papa
et des cas la rentrée du collège son
téléphone lui bloquer les appels
entrants et blot et sortant à partir de
17h pour que personne la contacte et au
collage et en fait ils ont commencé à
lui envoyer des mms parce que c'était la
seule chose qui était resté ouvert lui
faisait des captures d'écran pour
qu'elle rate pas au fait ce qu'on disait
sur elle
et
j'avais appelé plusieurs fois le collège
invite sol et gentiment je leur ai dit
moi je connais ses filles ne sont pas
méchantes il faut juste leur parler ou
appeler les parents ou faire quelque
chose parce que ma fille elle un peu
plus voilà quoi il faut arrêter et
m'ont demandé si c'était pas d'inaki et
j'en faisais trop
et en fait elle a fait une première
tentative au mois de mars
donc elle s'est retrouvée à l'hôpital
pendant une semaine
et
elle recevait fin que quelqu'un lui
envoyer un message en lui disant
on espère que la prochaine sera la bonne
là tout est raté mais t'inquiète pas la
prochaine sera la bonne
et elle était encore à l'hôpital à ce
moment là donc que j'ai appelé le
jacques les collèges pour leur expliquer
ce qui s'était passé
et le collège m'a dit mais c'est très
grave il va falloir porter plainte et
moi je voulais dit oui je le portais
plainte contre les parents des de ses
filles et contre le collège est en fait
d'un moment où j'ai dit contre le
collège s'est retourné contre moi oui
voilà alors ma fille elle a repris après
son hospitalisation elle a repris les
cours et ça a été encore pire qu'avant
c'était encore pire qu'avant parce que
elle me disait même là c'est maintenant
j'aurais même pu passer à côté d'elle
parce que le regard de travers où elle
rigolé sur son passage avec les autres
les filles donc ma fille me disait mais
si la cpe et le collège ne fait rien qui
peut faire quelque chose pour moi
donc je vais je lui ai demandé si elle
voulait qu'on aille porter plainte elle
m'a dit de toute façon
ça va empirer les choses
ça va empirer les choses elle avait plus
confiance en personne en fait tout
simplement et il ya eu le deuxième
confinement cas arriver donc elle était
bien elle avait repris un peu hein voilà
et en fait ce n'est que le président a
annoncé que l'école allait reprendre
ça y est c'est c'était reparti mon fils
me disais mais on peut pas faire ça à
distance on est obligé de partir à
l'école il reste trois semaines il y
avait le brevet donc j'ai demandé à ça
parce qu'elle était suivie par un
psychologue sa psychologue mais
juridiquement fiel avait des idées
noires qu'elle qu'elle supportait plus
d'aller à l'école
elle m'a dit on va peut-être l'interné
on va l'interné pour sa sécurité et
quand j'en ai parlé à ma fille m'a dit
non j'ai envie de faire mon brevet je
vois pas pourquoi je vais être un des
derniers mois j'ai un jeu c'est donc
rien à voir là dedans
s'il te plaît ne l'internet pas ne fait
pas ça donc elle a eu son brevet avec
mention très bien est lui 410 sur 400
donc c'est un objectif dépassé j'ai tu
vois malgré ton année de merde tu as
quand même assuré elle était aussi
traiter de sale intello parce qu'elle
posait beaucoup de questions en classe
les élèves ne supportait plus en fait la
supportait plus parce qu'elle était
toujours en elle l avait bien apprendre
à l'aimer bien à l'école et elle voulait
toujours à prendre quand un prof
demander ce que quelqu'un est une
question à poser c'est est toujours elle
qui avait la question à poser donc les
élèves l'attendait dans le couloir pour
la bousculer l'insulté moi je suis outré
par le comportement de l'établissement
excusez moi je suis pas ce que j'en
pensais chez vous mais c'est incroyable
de se sentir coupable la victime les
victimes on a l'impression que ce fonds
ce sont les autres c'est celle là
j'avais l'impression de la cuillère
quand on coupait les risques j'ai coupé
le téléphone lui couper tout j'avais
l'impression que c'était elle la fautive
elle recevait quel type de message
vous les avez vu ces messages euh ouais
mon avait montré quelques uns salat et
l'eau
sale lesbiennes tu t'habilles comme une
[ __ ] tu vaux rien ta maman aurait dû
avorter camp et est donc en été dont on
doit se revoir en fin de l'été dans son
ventre les petits trucs comme ça en fait
toutes et tous les prétextes étaient
bons pour est en fait tout le monde a
commencé là dernièrement jean n'a appris
parce qu'on a eu des élèves qui sont
venus nous voir pour nous dire qu'ils
avaient beaucoup plus que ce à quoi la
liste des harceleurs c'est s'est bien
allongé ouais
nous a expliqué qu'elle avait fait une
première tentative de suicide
comment il avait expliqué son geste
vous avez dit quoi vous avez dit j'en
pouvais plus je voulais m elle m'a dit
que quelques coups qu'elle n'en pouvait
plus que calme avait marre d'être
toujours critiquer quand elle allait à
l'école que qu'elle voulait juste à
tranquille un musée je veux juste être
tranquille m'habiller comme j'ai envie
aller à l'école apprendre et revenir
tranquille je comprends pas pourquoi
pourquoi je suis toujours chahutées
pourquoi on insulte dès que j'ouvre la
bouche dès que je dis quelque chose je
comprends pas elle avait quelques
copines qu'elle aimait bien qu'ils
venaient chez elle à la maison devant la
devant la grille de la maison je les
voyais à vélo patin à roulettes ou sable
je lisais médina vassor et à me disais
je ne peux pas parce que ces filles
viennent me voir en cachette
ou qu'elle ne pouvait pas dire qu'elle a
des copines avec elle voilà c'est
incroyable pas le dois dire que par
rapport aux autres elle pouvait pas dire
qu'elle était à copenhague dit non et
donc les autres avaient peur d'être la
cible donc elle préférait venir la voir
en cachette et la filière vers des
parties à jouer puis elle elle était là
derrière sa grille à les regarder moi
j'étais à la fenêtre regardez ma fille
impuissante impuissante je savais plus
quoi faire je sais il ya un moment où ça
limite vous êtes partis au maroc voir
oui en fait comme à l'aller superbe
revers rejoindre ses cousins on est
partis où elle a commencé elle a vu tous
ses cousins qu'elle n'avait pas vu
depuis qu'elle avait l'âge de 5 ans
d'ailleurs là ils sont dans un état
ils n'ont pas pu assister à
l'enterrement et
et nous attendent on va aller les voir
pour les quarante jours de ma fille ces
quarante jours où elle va partir ou pas
et là on va ils vont pouvoir nous voir
parce qu'ils nous attendent avec
impatience ils ont suivi la marche
blanche en direct du marin mais comment
comment comment même la famille comment
votre mari ont réagi à une telle
nouvelle honda je le dis voilà c'est on
se dit mais on va
on va faire on va faire un il va y avoir
un drame on
comment vous avez fait avec
l'établissement vous et qu'est-ce que
vous avez qu'est ce qui vous a dit merci
d'établissements mais qu'est-ce qui vous
ont dit l'établissement en fait ils sont
venus à l'enterrement
le dinar est décédé le lundi soir ils
sont venus le vendredi à l'enterrement
ils m'ont dit que ils ont été obligés de
mettre en place une cellule
psychologique pour la cpi les poings
serrés mais ce sont eux les victimes
mais je te jure intéressés et
donc je les ai appelés j'ai appelé la
vie scolaire pour parler avec une
personne avec qui je m'entendais très
bien et avec qui est en fait je vous
l'avais demandé de surveiller ma fille
après la première tentative
je les appelais parce que là le collège
me disais que cette personne ne leur
avait jamais dit que j'appelais
donc quand je les ai eus au téléphone
effectivement il m'a dit non je ne me
rappelle pas qu'on avait appelé alors je
l'appelais tous les jours il m'a dit non
non moi je tiens à montrer à ajouter à
mon poste ce qui m'a répondu il m'a dit
vous savez le collège n'a rien à voir
avec l'histoire d'autrui venez l'équipe
est là pour vous écouter pour vous savez
quand on laisse quand on laisse les
enfants dans un collège dans un lycée
dans un dans un établissement on se dit
qu'ils sont en sécurité dont on confie
nos enfants mine de rien à des personnes
compte qu'ils vous disent on n'a rien à
voir là dedans alors que c'est la cause
de la mort de dina excusez moi et moi ça
me rend fou je suis désolé c'est si
incroyable juste en plus ce que je vois
c'est que généralement dans ces cas là
les jeunes filles qui sont harcelés ou
les jeunes garçons n'en parle très peu
on parle très peu avec leurs parents
avec leur famille vous on voit que vous
aviez pris des mesures pour qu'elle voit
pas le harcèlement dire que vous étiez
vraiment quand tout allait changer
beaucoup avec vous oui parce que en fait
on vivait à trois avec mon mari
mes deux fils chacun sont étudiants et
vivent avec nous dans pendant trois ans
j'ai vécu que avec dina donc on était
très très proches vraiment très très
proches donc elle me parlait de tout ce
qui est de tout ce qu'elle vivait et
j'essaie de lui depuis ce qu'elle me
disait souvent qu'elle était très seul
que qu'elle veut qu'elles pouvaient pas
elle n'arrivait pas à être seul et je
lisais essayer de tout trouver d'autres
d'autres copines peut-être celle là elle
te mérite pas mais elle me dit je sais
c'était celle-là qu'elle voulait c'était
là qu'elle voulait alors ryan c'est
grâce à toi que les médias ont eu vent
de ce drame qui vous touche pense était
très important lancé c'est un drame qui
malheureusement ramènera pas dina ce
qu'on aurait voulu mais qu'a posté ce
week-end une vidéo
extraordinaire sur les réseaux très très
touchante c'est un hommage à ta soeur à
la personne qu'elle était je vous
propose de la regarder
[Musique]
le tueur denis
oh
alors ryan
c'est vrai que cette vidéo elle est
incroyable
quand tu fais pour aller de l'avant
aujourd'hui je vais pas de l'avant j'y
vais pas
elle me manque chaque seconde que
j'avais fait ma soeur me manque
ils me l'ont enlevé
on s'appelait tous les soirs
vous montrer comment elle s habille
lendemain pour aller en cours
on faisait des lunchs time on appelle ça
des lunch times ont mangé ensemble en
festin de vue que j'habitais pas à la
maison
quand ça allait par a même demandé de
l'appeler je l'appelais se confier à moi
j'essaie de rentrer le maximum les
week-ends et les vacances je passais
tout mon temps avec elle je faisais de
la musique avec elle on écrivait des
chansons chantées
et maintenant et puis la magie et la
puissance j'ai dû l'appeler pour lui
dire que sa soeur était décédé je le
fais en quatre fois alors qu'elle était
déjà morte j'ai pas osé lui annoncer la
nouvelle comme ça je les fais en quatre
fois et c'est au bout de la quatrième
que je vais elle est partie et
comprenait pas qu'on me disait que je le
disais les parties comprenait pas ce que
je voulais dire comprenez pas j'avais
tellement peur de lui annoncer la
nouvelle parce qu'ils étaient
fusionnelle avec sa soeur
je suis désolé rien n'est trop s'excuse
m'en
protéger
non t'excuses pas l'export
pas faire vivre avec ça à faire j'avais
que ça à faire
c'est
du passé
rien aujourd'hui c'est quoi ton combat
ça ma soeur dans un premier temps je
veux que ses harceleurs et c'est
harceleuse el pais il paye c'est pour ce
qu'ils ont fait ils m'ont enlevé ma
soeur ils m'ont enlevé ma soeur j'ai
plus de serge en avait qu'une seule il
me l'a enlevé et je veux qu'ils paient
pour ça
je vais aussi que tous ceux qui qui se
font harceler je me suis phare celui ci
étant plus jeune tout ce qu'ils soient
harcelées
qu'ils sachent qu'ils peuvent parler ils
peuvent parler à leurs parents même si
t'es pas facile si c'est pas facile de
se confier parfois ils peuvent parler
il ya des gens qui sont là pour les
écouter
quoi ça n'a pas marché pour maintenant
pourquoi ça n'a pas marché pour dinan
on a fait tout ce qu'il fallait on est
allé voir les enseignants on allait voir
les cités on allait voir la vie scolaire
ça n'a pas marché
et à la télé par le faisait harcèlement
il parle des programmes jeu et après
quand on va les voir ils nous disent non
c'est des gamineries c'est votre fiel en
fait elle en fait un peu trop c'est je
me rappelle d'une semaine
particulièrement ou mais j'étais revenu
chez mes parents pendant une semaine ils
étaient au travail il n'y a pas un jour
où le collège n'a pas appelé trois ou
quatre fois dans la journée pour nous
dire venez la chercher à la par vidal en
cours elle se sent pas bien la mal au
ventre elle a mal à la tête c'est venait
la chercher venait la chercher mais
vraiment tous les jours tous les jours
de la semaine et à aucun moment ils se
sont dit un souci et vient de leur
établissement il ya une carence
éducative et elle vient de leur
établissement à aucun moment ils sont
remis en question le problème il venait
de ma soeur
je vous dis on est on je pense que les
téléspectateurs sont comme nous on est
révolté par ce qui s'est passé est
révolté par le manque de réaction de
décision
ryan je me mets à ta place
un moment tu es tu avoir une aura juneau
n je laisse les autres jours je vais
toujours j'allais toujours
aujourd'hui vous avez des contacts avec
l'établissement aujourd'hui vous voulez
comme a dit ryan et c'est vrai qu'on a
tous ont mis bien sûr que ça ramène rage
la médina et le drame il et
j'ai malheureusement
aujourd'hui
on pourra pas revenir en arrière mais
c'est la dix neuvième victime de
harcèlement cette année j'aimerais bien
savoir qui sont les autres gina c'est la
19ème cette année c'est énorme
aujourd'hui
vous savez qui sont ses harceleurs vous
les avez
oui on a des noms on a une glisse on
sait qu'il faut serrer leur adresse leur
numéro on va les preuves vont vous avez
america l'ajax avait même appelé les
parents m'ont - non non non non on va
faire les choses en restent là c'est bon
maintenant dina est parti ça d'appeler
les parents mer mais même avant avant
vous laisser le but avant
on avait espéré que le collège le fasse
c'est ça qu'on voulait on voulait que ça
se fasse officiellement avec le collège
je voulais pas appelé par an par part en
part par an je voulais que je voulais
acquis aujourd'hui le plus au corps
enseignant au collège juin au collège où
la joie nal pas les professeurs mais la
cpe la direction du collège et en
deuxième temps bâle et
les harceleurs penser que
l'établissement doit être condamné
oui carceller aussi bien dans ton
harceleur aussi bien sûr je suis je
trouve que c'est pas normal ce qui se
passe c'est pas possible non louis
vachon en fait c'est une injustice en sa
personne en enregistre où ça révoltant
et c'est vrai qu'on a eu maille n'ya pas
sur ce plateau qui parlait beaucoup de
ça c'est pas normal aujourd'hui qu'une
famille soit soit détruite et est alors
évidemment ça l'a ramène un pas mais il
faut absolument que les nas ou pas morte
pour rien c'est on ne peut pas accepter
sans sur ensemble surtout tous les
jeunes qui nous regarde oui impossible
et les jeunes qui nous regardent le
harcèlement je vous dis si c'est un truc
de lâches c'est un truc de volos c'est
pour les tocards
johnny c'est
c'est une fierté de harceler une
personne en difficulté une personne qui
est qui est différente la personne qui a
envie de vivre différemment de vous au
contraire je vous le dit ou passé pas
pour des roues
c'est
si pitoyable
donc tous les harceleurs peut-être de
jeunes qui nous regardent
je vous dise et
si vous êtes tout sauf des roues
vraiment
et tous il ya des personnes qui sont
harcelés n'hésitez pas dites le et soyez
forts dites le et vous savez c'est
peut-être des moments difficiles à
passer pendant quelque temps mais ça va
s'arranger après si vous parlez si vous
le dites si vous le fait savoir et s'ils
arrivent à faire bouger les choses et si
les choses bougent comme médina l'adil
et c'est vrai mais le problème qu'hier
vous voyez vous voyez l'exemple de
samira vous dit samira la raison tout à
l'heure je vous ai entendu vous avez dit
on a fait tout comme il fallait parce
que c'est moi que je lui ai posé la
question de talent je vous ai dit vous
étiez au courant vous vous parlez
beaucoup avec votre fille il faut
vraiment que les établissements il faut
vraiment qu'un gouvernement soit
beaucoup plus sensibles à ça beaucoup
plus sévère envers les établissements le
problème qu'il ya dans les
établissements et juni c'est ça qui est
insupportable c'est que les
établissements sont notés et que les
établissements ils n'ont qu'une trouille
c'est d'abord une mauvaise note donc ils
veulent pas faire de bruit ils veulent
pas faire et il va y mettre tous sous le
tapis et ça c'est inadmissible si
peut-être qu'il faut changer cette c'est
cette manière de noter les
établissements parce que c'est ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui il ya des drames qui
se passe parce que le les établissements
ils ont tellement peur d'avoir une dette
mal notés ils ont tellement peur que ça
fasse du bruit ils ont tellement peur
que ce soit médiatisé qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai eu plein d'affaires comme ça et à
chaque fois les parents me disaient non
mais les professeurs nous dit hannon si
vous mettez attiser le truc on veut pas
il ya dix jours dit le même le lycée où
ma soeur elle était par exemple moi je
le dis on a fait la marche blanche donc
il ya des organisateurs qui sont gérés
de la marche blanche qui nous ont
rappelés lycée pour les prévenir que la
marche à ça finirait devant le lycée
donc que les roses et les fleurs et tout
ce qui s'ensuit à les déposer devant est
la principale digicel radis mais une
fois que la marche est défini vous
balayer le trottoir vous en cas de nul
non
mais pas être ligne et
c5 c6 n'a
rien à voir avec le lycée au contraire
les élèves de 6es il se bat depuis que
ma soeur elle est morte pour obtenir une
minute de silence mais bon ma soeur vu
qu'elle était depuis trois semaines
scolarisés n'était pas connu ça va
remuer plus qu'autre chose les les
adolescents si on faisait quelque chose
alors c'est mieux qu'on fasse rire c'est
les paroles de de la principale du lycée
alors que lycées ans en la matière était
heureuse là bas
ryan c'est un mirage
vous habitez maintenant avec votre mari
oui comment comment vous arrivez à vous
reconstruire je sais pas je sais pas je
sais pas ce qu'on va devenir là on est
super bien entouré il ya toujours plein
plein de monde les gens sont relais tous
les jours
mais ryan va repartir je vais me
retrouver avec mon mari et il va falloir
continuer à vivre et sincèrement je ne
sais pas parce que toute ma vie a tourné
autour de dina tout ce que je faisais
c'était par rapport à l mon emploi du
temps c'était par rapport à l ma vie
entière tourner autour d'elle et
maintenant je sais pas je suis perdu
je sais pas je sais pas ce que je vais
devenir je sais pas
là maintenant tout de suite quand je
pense à elle je me dis je suis rentrée
elle va peut-être être la même pour la
marche je suis allé je voulais aller la
voir lui demander ce qu'elle allait
mettre pour la marche parce que je sais
c'est
elle fait partie de moi donc j'ai
toujours l'impression qu'elle est
qu'elle ait là quoi
jeunes ont créé par le petit déj il faut
que j'aille la chercher je vais je vois
là et quand ryan va partir je veux je
vais me retrouver tout seul je sais que
j'ai mon mari et tout mais je vais me
retrouver tout seul je vais me retrouver
tout seul je sais pas comment ça va se
passer
j'adore j'ai peur de l'avenir mais
tout cas vous avez été je vous dis on a
vu ce que vous avez dit à la marche on
vous écoute tous les deux ryan et samira
et je vous trouverons extraordinaire je
pense que votre combat maintenant aussi
c'est que ça ne se reproduise plus je
sais que miles est c'est le combat de
ryan c'est votre combat aussi samira
est vraiment je vous le dis si vous avez
de quoi que ce soit et que l'on fasse
n'importe quoi pour vous pour faire
avancer les choses bien entendu on sera
toujours là pour vous sachez le vraiment
vous n'hésitez jamais je vous dis vous
êtes juste
incroyable et le seul problème je vous
dis vous l'avez dit le seul truc qui me
fait peur et ça doit être pareil pour
les téléspectateurs
si vous avez dit on a fait tout comme il
fallait et pourtant le drame est arrivé
et ça
c'est plus en béton je trouve ce soit
merci d'avoir été avec nous
en tout cas on veut avoir des nouvelles
de ce qui se passe et on sait que
l'administration parfois ça peut être
long ça peut être
un petit peu sinueux on peut essayer une
fois que le drame est passé on peut
essayer de faire traîner les choses
sachez qu'ici si ça traîne on fera tout
pour que ça bouge très très vite et on
remet sûrs à 6 l et r pour que justice
soit faite donc on sera on va suivre
cette affaire et on veut que ça aille
très très vite donc on fera tout pour on
va partir dans une semaine au maroc pour
la ranger de ma fille et au retour bien
sûr j'ai pu rien à faire que de notre
calme et on est on sera là pour vous
aider même si vous avez besoin d'avocat
si vous avez besoin de quoi que ce soit
on sera là pour vous je vous le dit et
on fera avancer les choses et que cette
histoire ne soit pas mis sous le tapis